got a disease in your heart bruh
it's killing your fat
the film is about a 14 year old boy
named Darius who comes home from school
and summer and gets caught up in this
escalating conflict between Malcolm his
father and Porter a kind of mysterious
Drifter so Daddy night little man it's
really about a boy becoming a man Darius
does have a temper he's endured a lot
and that temper only helps him to push
it back out the title is based on
someone who's calling into the anger and
the masculinity traps
Porter is the mysterious loner it's an
obvious contrast for Malcolm right they
grew up in the same space and they
manage the cast in very very different
ways
come on it feels like Moonlight With
Thrill and a little bit more tension the
two men in the film reflect the
polarities of the African-American male
experience one being attached one being
unattached they're two alpha males
anytime you have two Alphas together you
know someone's gonna have to win it's a
tumultuous family Brotherhood
the relationship between Darius and
Malcolm why I really love this character
is because he just keeps persevering he
doesn't quit even at the last frame he's
still going after his boy I know it
doesn't seem like it all the time but
I'm really trying near Darius in the
black Cinema Canon where there's just
massive gaps of like what we have and
haven't seen there's so much space for
young filmmakers of color to put
themselves out there in a very unique
and interesting way it was my first film
so it was a lot of preparation as a
black filmmaker you kind of need to
write the stories for black actors and
black characters that don't exist and
that you can't wait for and you can't
find
I love doing pieces like this that are
really small and intimate as reflective
of My Life the Story the poeticism the
feeling that I haven't seen often from
anybody that I think only black
filmmakers can really gift people
because of our understanding
open this door now just the emotion did
a roller coaster of emotions man
it's a wild ride but it's just it's a
dope story period
no dessert
yeah yeah it's the Kung Fu dude right
you know it's got to be the biggest
gotta know what you're doing you know
thank you
[Music]